[Music]
Modern Warfare is back and it's
dominating twitch streamers everywhere
have caught the caught bug and at one
point it was the second most watched
game on the platform behind League of
Legends
[Applause]
[Music]
Tim the top man doctor disrespect and
Shroud are just a few of the big name
streamers grinding the game out non-stop
and with Cod streams surging in
popularity a familiar face has returned
to the platform so for those of you who
don't follow Call of Duty scum P is an
absolute legend and arguably the best
player to ever pick up a controller the
guys want a [ __ ] ton of tournaments
including a world championship and he's
still an elite player almost a decade
into his career
now stump has a stream since March since
he's been entirely focused on the cwl
but since he's returned the guy hasn't
missed a beat in the two weeks since
Modern Warfare's release scope has
become the third biggest Cod streamer on
Twitch his first stream back peaked at
13,000 viewers since then hump has gone
live almost every day pub stomping
randoms calling in nukes and above all
else just being funny as [ __ ] on street
but longtime fans have noticed that
something's missing something green look
you can use any optic you want a really
big deal or no or no and that we did no
optic around there after almost a decade
with the org sculpt is no longer on
optic he left the team last month and
he's still getting used to it as always
folks this is a boy stop it's weird
scum post optic is like somebody living
their best life after getting out of a
shitty relationship scum Panoptix seemed
like an inseparable pair but as the
organization fell apart under new
management
scums home came crashing down at a
certain point you knew it was gonna when
it was gonna happen I didn't think was
gonna happen like this like so
maliciously with the brand well new
ownership means more money for optic it
comes at the cost of the identity of the
greenwall an optic is no longer the team
run by hex the one that fans fell in
love with in the first place you have to
try to to mess up up they're gonna try
really hard know but they didn't they
didn't it was just it came natural to
them scum jumped off optics sinking ship
and joined NRG he was co-ceo now happens
to be hacks give me a little bit more
energy energy energy cure energy
scum pool play for the Chicago Huntsman
in the upcoming cod league and he's also
reunited with his old t2 P duo formal
well we don't know how skumps new team
will play on the main stage he's
surrounded by fellow world champions and
MVPs and with hex running the show this
Chicago team looks to be the spiritual
successor to optic even though that
brand still exists in the cod league
under optic Los Angeles for skunk fans
his decision to keep playing is
bittersweet because once the season
starts streaming and playing
competitively will become much more
harder to balance I enjoyed streaming
again at the start of black ops 4 but
then it got to a certain point where I
had to choose between competitive and
playing again because my team they want
to stream scram skunk has a proven
history and dominating and Cod but being
the best means that you need to give up
something in return and for skunk that
means giving up constant content
creation to focus on playing
competitively at least for now
now retiring comes 100 days and let's
get this back so that's not gonna happen
100 thieves yeah are you guys
franchising cuz you need to with that's
a we said now retiring oh yeah I wanted
you to retire I had nothing to do with
anything oh you wanted me to retire I
want you to retire scums not retiring
anytime soon
the dude still has a couple of years
left in him and that champs this year he
proved that he's still an elite player
[Applause]
but look even if scomp stops streaming
has consistently come the new season
this moment has been a blast for cod
fans because it reminds us why we fell
in love with him in the first place
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages